my picture of the week is definitely  Mark Zuckerberg walking past a room full  of people wearing virtual reality  headsets the picture created quite a  steer on social media with people  calling it disturbing horrible even  awful the same way even social media was  scary just a couple of years ago now  people are very much afraid of this  thing called virtual reality just think  about it a couple of decades ago even  comic books were perceived as a complete  threat on children's mental health today  I'm pretty sure parents would be  delighted if their kids would read comic  books I personally felt that their  reactions to the picture were even more  astonishing than the picture itself yes  it's true there is something a bit  creepy about a room full of people  completely ignoring each other however  this is definitely not the first time a  new technology is being mocked just days  or months or years before becoming a  complete standard  you  you